le liban avant le 17 octobre et le liban
après le 17 octobre
donc aujourd'hui je vais dire ces jeunes
qui sont dans la rue qui nous représente
tous aujourd'hui ont pu faire quand même
d'aider succès donc don qui est mené à
la chute du gouvernement ils ont empêché
la formation ou la nomination de
plusieurs ministres est aujourd'hui il
demande un gouvernement de technocrates
sous 48 heures mon message écouter ça
peut se passer comme ça peut ne pas se
passer si on va aller un peu plus loin à
mon avis ce n'est pas vraiment là où ça
se passe parce que finalement si c'est
pour avoir un gouvernement qui
équivalent à l'ancien gouvernement ou
dans la même structure avec les mêmes
forces politicienne on n'a rien fait
donc il faut très bien comprendre c'est
quoi les causes qui ont poussé les gens
sur la rue qui la crise sociale qui est
le problème monétaire qui est le manque
de liquidité sur le sur le terrain qui
la dégradation du niveau de vie donc
c'est des grands problèmes
et tout d'abord le gouvernement qui soit
technocrates ou pas évidemment qu'on
veut avoir de technocrates pourquoi les
gens devant des technocrates parce
qu'ils veulent changer du paysage actuel
des politiciens